eigentlich kennen wir kohlendioxid als
klimaschädliches treibhausgas und die
wissenschaft sucht nach wegen ist
irgendwie aus der atmosphäre zu
bekommen aber jetzt dreht sich alles es
könnte als treibstoff verwendet werden
ein österreichisches forschungsteam hat
jetzt beides geschafft sie haben einen
prozess erforscht wie aus dem
herausgefilterten treibhausgas zudem
noch treibstoff produziert werden kann
und dass zudem auch noch äußerst
effizient wie das genau funktioniert und
ob das jetzt das ende aller klima
probleme dieser welt bedeutet jetzt
wirklich zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit haben der vergangenheit schon
einige ideen vorgestellt um co2 in
andere stoffe umzuwandeln ein
schweizerisches forschungsteam
beispielsweise will bis 2025 ein prozent
der globalen co2 emissionen aus der luft
filtern und damit pflanzen
denn in der richtigen dosierung
eingesetzt sorgt kohlendioxid
tatsächlich dafür dass gemüse
schneller wächst und zwar bis zu 20
prozent eine andere idee ist es dass co2
in unterirdischen hohlräumen
gespeichert wird
das ist ja immer wieder ein thema bei
uns noch grandioser wäre es natürlich
wenn das herausgefilterten kohlendioxid
als treibstoff nutzbar gemacht werden
könnte und es gibt bereits methoden die
das ermöglichen doch das problem
hierbei es werden seltene erden oder
aber extrem hohe temperaturen benötigt
um die moleküle aufzuspalten bislang
ist das mehr als unrentabel jetzt hat
ein internationales forschungsteam aus
österreich eine lösung für dieses
problem gefunden sie haben erforscht
dass sich statt der teuren und seltene
metalle auch synthetische polymere
nutzen lassen
diese sind dem melanin also unseren haut
pigmenten nachempfunden diese polymere
sind allerdings nicht leitfähig und
somit als katalysator erst einmal nicht
denkbar also katalysator ist eine
zwischenstation für den chemischen
prozess in einem ersten schritt hat das
forschungsteam diese also zunächst
einmal durch einen chemischen prozess
leitfähig gemacht kohlendioxid kann so
in methan säure und kohlenmonoxid
aufgespalten werden mit andere wiederum
kann dann in einem weiteren prozess im
wasserstoff umgewandelt werden oder
direkt als treibstoff genutzt werden und
zwar für ameisensäure brennstoffzellen
eine brennstoffzelle bei der
ameisensäure als elektrolyt genutzt
wird sie wird beispielsweise
energielieferant für smartphones
kameras oder laptops genutzt werden
letztendlich kann man dieses prinzip mit
den natürlichen prozessen in der natur
vergleichen auch hier neben pflanzen co2
auf und verwandeln es mit hilfe von
sonnenlicht in biomoleküle wie uns dann
beispielsweise in form von holz als
treibstoff zur verfügung stehen das
forschungsteam aus österreich hat die
stabilität und leistungsfähigkeit in
einem stundenlangen test demonstriert
hierbei wurde kohlendioxid mit hilfe von
elektrischen strom in ameisensäure und
kohlenmonoxid umgewandelt beide stoffe
können wiederum als treibstoff
verwendet werden und würden so
tatsächlich den kohlenstoff zyklus
schließen der effizienz dieses
prozesses also die umwandlung von
elektrischer in chemische energie ist
vergleichbar mit der effizienz die sonst
nur bei katalysatoren auf metall basis
erreicht wird das ganze erinnert ein
bisschen an eine idee eines harvard
forschungsteams das hatte sich bakterien
zu nutze gemacht und diese mit metallen
wie cadmium ausgestattet dadurch
bildeten diese bakterien kristalle auf
ihrer oberfläche aus die an halbleiter
erinnern und den bakterien eigentlich
als schutzmechanismus dienen
doch gleichzeitig versetzen sie die
bakterien damit in die lage
künstliche photosynthese zu betreiben
die cyborg bakterien ziehen nämlich
kohlendioxid aus der umgebung wenn sie
wasser und licht ausgesetzt werden
daraus produzieren sie essigsäure was
dann als basis für treibstoff dienen
kann der prozess ist bislang noch nicht
effizient denn noch total simpel
tatsächlich also sinnvoll dass
forschungsteams weltweit weiter intensiv
an solchen ideen tüfteln dennoch
sollten wir dabei nicht vergessen der
prozess co2 aus der atmosphäre zu
nutzen um kraftstoffe herzustellen
trägt nur zu einem kleinen teil zum
klimaschutz bei diese technologie eignet
sich bei aller euphorie noch nicht dazu
die mengen an co2 aus der atmosphäre zu
ziehen die nötig wären um die globale
erwärmung zu verlangsamen oder gar zu
stoppen
dazu müsste das kohlendioxid dauerhaft
aus dem kreislauf entfernt werden unser
job muss es also weiterhin ganz dringend
sein dafür zu sorgen dass die co2
emissionen drastisch gesenkt werden
hierbei klickst du halt ich euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn ihr
kein video zum thema co2 klimawandel und
so weiter und so fort verpassen wollte
und auch zu allen anderen themen dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
und hier geht es weiter und ich will
wirklich noch mal betonen ist ganz
wichtig was interessiert mich das klima
response in folge 05 da sprechen
klimaforscher mojib latif und ich über
den klimawandel ein richtig richtig
wichtiges video der bundeszentrale für
politische bildung also auf keinen fall
phasen draufklicken und ansonsten bis
dann
bleibt dran